les agriculteurs voient parfois des amis
ou des collègues partir sans avoir
décelé chez eux le moindre signe de
désespoir
le choc est brutal c'est justement à la
suite du suicide de l'un des leurs que
les producteurs de l'île d'orléans ont
décidé de se mobiliser et de mettre en
place des services pour mieux intervenir
en cas de détresse
[Musique]
et
l'île d'orléans incrédule thouars d'à
peine 190 km² située à un jet de pierre
de la ville de québec
le paysage est bucolique mais derrière
ce décor champêtre la détresse est
présente
selon les chiffres du bureau du coroner
du québec
trente-trois personnes ont mis fin à
leurs jours entre 1990 et marche 2018
certains étaient producteurs agricoles
sur leurs liens depuis quelques années
on a perdu des des collègues des
posteurs qui étaient ici ça nous touche
énormément
produite en commun de proche de moi qui
extrait la vie c'est un bleu - qui a
grandi avec moi
puis tout dernièrement dernières années
ont été ceux des comités ensemble tous
le connaissais pas seulement sur l'île
mais partout au québec il ya personne
qui l'avait vraiment venir donc je pense
que ça l'a amplifié un peu l'état de
choc et généralisé consentait marjolaine
surcote une productrice agricole était à
chier à son île
je la porte dans mon coeur c'est une
belle communauté tissée serrée
marjolaine fait partie de la jeune
relève sa famille habitent sur ses
terres depuis huit générations
hélas beaucoup p6t à reprendre
l'entreprise familiale
ma plus grande crainte car j'ai plus à
décision de prendre la relève
c'était d'échouer fille d'un jour avoir
des difficultés financières qui mettrait
la pérennité de l'entreprise en péril
échoués là où ses ancêtres ont réussi
être celui qui met fin au patrimoine
familial
c'est souvent un lourd fardeau à porter
pour les producteurs
sans compter les heures de travail qui
n'en finissent plus ces deux journées de
12 heures on essaie de ne pas dépasser 6
jours semaines en v6 protéger des fois
on fait se disent il faut se parler
surtout quand on vit dans le milieu de
travail
quand la mort de stéphane blouin
survient en février 2019
marjolaine turcotte décide de faire
bouger les choses
comme ma famille a été touchée par ce
signe et quelques années moi ça m'a
profondément attristé j'étais vraiment
dans tous mes états on s'en sort comment
on s'en sort en prenant action en
canalisant
l'énergie de la colère en faisant
quelque chose de positif canaliser
l'énergie pour marjolaine surcote cela
signifiait mettre en place un comité de
producteurs son but agir pour prévenir
et détecter la détresse psychologique et
le suicide des agriculteurs plus la
rencontre qu'on appelle en mars le
producteur est invité on leur dit qu'ils
avaient des accents qui allait découler
que vous ayez déjà eu l'information
sentinelle en avril
[Applaudissements]
les sentinelles ce sont les yeux et les
oreilles sur le terrain aujourd'hui
c'est jour de formation
la majorité des participants sont des
producteurs agricoles mais il ya aussi
une directrice des comptes dans une
institution financière et un camionneur
des professionnels et des travailleurs
qui côtoie régulièrement les
agriculteurs ils viennent chercher des
outils pour mieux intervenir
on va commencer un mode solo on va
parler du rôle n'est détecté des signes
de détresse psychologique n'est pas
facile la sentinelle doit déceler le non
dit le producteur en détresse à des
difficultés de sommeil se sont plus
tristes plus évitable plus colérique il
éprouve des difficultés concentration le
sujet de l'heure encore camille multi
prospère au sommet c'est quand même de
tradition est-ce qu'on voit cette
semaine une moins bonne prise en charge
60 et de moins bonnes qui passe chercher
de l'aide à en parler ça vous et comme
ayant cédé faiblesse
la sentinelle doit poser des questions
surtout posé la question afin de
s'assurer que la personne n'a pas
d'idées suicidaires et si besoin elle
doit l'encourager à aller chercher
l'aide de professionnels
je pense quelle question je vois
jusqu'où je pensais pas que les
participants en sont conscients
la présence de sentinelle en milieu
agricole ne mettra pas fin à tous les
suicides sur l'île
même si en fait il en va des chapélies
beauté fait tout ce qu'on veut les
agriculteurs sont de moins en moins
nombreux ils se côtoient peu et sont de
plus en plus isolé pour réduire les
risques
le comité veut briser l'isolément des
producteurs pourrait tout d'abord vous
remercier d'être là puis vous féliciter
tous les producteurs qui est ici
aujourd'hui est d'avoir osé prendre un
break d'avancé osé couper vote était en
deux organisations de barbecue en plein
coeur de l'été
envoi de cartes postales et de plaques
est monté un rappel constant aux
producteurs qu'il doit prendre soin de
lui l'île d'orléans n'est pas la seule
région où les producteurs agricoles
s'organise
[Musique]
rama yade sports - fait consume on était
un petit chez patrice parme à chaque
fois ce matin à normandin au lac saint
jean
ils sont une trentaine de producteurs à
répondre à l'appel lancé par daniel
barry et mélissa verrou mois salle
comble
c'est l'occasion de parler de problèmes
et de solutions mais une demande revient
constamment la présence de travailleurs
de rentrer dans les régions legault la
gagne on loge pas bien on continue
d'avoir maintenir la passion c'est une
bonne saison
[Musique]